[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
mientras los países de acogida se
preguntan cómo atender la llegada de
inmigrantes y refugiados a sus
territorios existen iniciativas
individuales que ayudan a su integración
uno de los principales obstáculos para
los que dejaron su hogar en busca de
mejores oportunidades es el idioma y por
eso un ciudadano español decidió abrir
el garaje de su casa para enseñar la
lengua a migrantes africanos que
cruzaron el atlántico y llegaron hasta
las islas canarias conozcamos a
continuación la historia de titto martín
moore estuvo 14 días la deriva antes de
llegar a costas españolas un viaje que
lo llevó de senegal a europa en busca de
una vida distinta 'el hobbit' 19 empujó
a muchos a emigrar y planteó un
sinnúmero de desafíos para las
comunidades de acogida
ante ese reto tito martín decidió actuar
movió las cosas de su cochera y ubicó
una sala de estudio improvisada para
enseñar a jóvenes africanos la lengua
española
si tu partido es un ciudadano normal y
corriente que de lo que piensa que hay
para todos
y que veía empezó a ver en lo relativo a
la emigración la llegada de migrantes a
gran canarias mi isla y decidió que ya
estaba bien de dar me gusta a las
noticias oa los comentarios que estaban
en contra de eso y decidió pasar a la
acción para lograrlo contó con la suerte
de encontrar a otras personas con su
mismo ideal fue así como isabel se unió
a su iniciativa
pido número de tipo y le digo oye tito
se estima soy profesora de español
francés e inglés que puedo hacer y me
dijo issa necesitamos ayuda para enseñar
español digo oh dios mío es que me lo
pone tan a mano y para jóvenes como amor
esta oportunidad es su primer
acercamiento a una escuela
quito dijo mis sean bien en mi casa para
scola hacer español aprender de español
muy fácil en casa de tito no sólo
reciben educación su vivienda es refugio
seguro para los migrantes aquí también
pueden recibir una ducha y alimentarse
bueno pues los chicos lo que he tenido
de agradecimiento primero que nada a
pesar de su situación de
desesperación porque ellos estos en
concreto quieren quedarse en gran
canaria porque se sienten bien tratados
porque le gusta lo que ven no tienen a
nadie en la península que los espere
según el ministerio de interior de
españa entre enero y julio de este año
siete mil 260 migrantes desembarcaron en
las islas canarias
[Aplausos]
en 2008 con el ingreso de miles de
menores a eeuu surgió la visa juvenil un
documento que le permitió a los jóvenes
de entre 18 y 21 años legalizar su
estatus migratorio apoyados en un
guardián legal en nueva york' nuestra
corresponsal mamen sala encontró al
padre fabián arias un religioso que ha
apadrinado a más de 100 jóvenes bajo
esta figura
ya que estamos recibiendo dar un nuevo
hijo un nuevo hermano hijo querido cómo
estás el que graba las imágenes que
acaban de ver es el padre fabián desde
esta iglesia en pleno centro de
manhattan ayuda a jóvenes indocumentados
que llegan a nueva york lo hace
convirtiéndose en su guardián legal
están huyendo de una violencia en el
cual fueron sometidos maltratados
abusados
que sea por las maras otras por otros
organización evento hacer poder
acompañarnos en este proceso para que
puedan emocionarnos para que puedan
realmente
más saludablemente y mentalmente
qué tal cómo está él me dijo diego que
quería hablar conmigo el teléfono
siempre está disponible para hacer
muchos hijos como él los llama uno de
ellos es césar trabaja como repartidor
de comida gracias a la tutela legal de
este pastor luterano
llegó de méxico hace dos años cuando
tenía 17 yendo de la violencia de su
país y con un objetivo claro mi sueño
pues es seguir estudiando porque pues yo
dije me dio mi estudio por venir aquí
todos mis sueños seguir estudiando y
poder tener este
trabajo desde esta iglesia que están
viendo detrás de mí el padre fabián ha
apadrinado legalmente a cerca de 130
jóvenes en los últimos 14 años algunos
de ellos siguen bajo su tutela pero
otros muchos incluso han conseguido
convertirse en ciudadanos
estadounidenses
es el caso de hermes otro mexicano que
puso rumbo a eeuu hace 14 años
nada más llegar a nueva york busco una
iglesia para pedir ayuda ahí donde
conocí el padre fabián él me ayudó a
conseguir una casa comida y una
estabilidad legal el pasado 14 de
febrero recibió su pasaporte
norteamericano
objetivo conseguido ahora toca trabajar
para seguir cumpliendo sueños en la
ciudad de los rascacielos
la de tito y el padre fabián son
iniciativas solidarias y decisiones que
ayudan a jóvenes migrantes que
encuentran en el idioma y en su estatus
migratorio una barrera para avanzar en
un nuevo país y el dato de emigración de
la semana con un mural interactivo en la
barrera que se levanta en la frontera
entre méxico y eeuu una artista plasma
el testimonio de 15 inmigrantes que
llegaron a la unión americana cuando
eran niños y que años más tarde fueron
deportados a méxico al no ser incluidos
en el programa de acción diferida para
los que llegaron en la infancia
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]